are overtraining yeah buddy you've heard that right you are overtraining and i'm 100 sure 99 sure that you are overtraining why because most of people are overtraining in arm wrestling and i'm gonna tell you why so we usually come to arm wrestling from different strength sports we have split
trainings for our chest, back, push-pull, legs, whatever.
We are quite used to train multiple times a week.
The fitness in arm wrestling, this is one muscle group and we hit this over and over again and it's really hard to isolate muscles.
You can do it,
But you will never be 100% sure that you can go day after day hitting different parts of muscles and you will be fine.
Unless you're gonna cut your volume.
And this is what it is about.
I'm not telling you to not split your pronation from supination, cupping from wrist extension.
Do whatever you think you like.
we're gonna discuss this later on this channel how to structure training properly but what I'm saying that principles that we used to believe are 100% sure sacred let's say in sports strength will not apply here because isolation just is impossible like pure isolation so if one day you are going let's say
Good example, side pressure, okay?
So you are maxing your side pressure or you are doing some volume, I don't know, two exercises, four sets, 85% of your max, like classic bodybuilding stuff.
You, the next day, if you will try to use, let's say that was side pressure, and then, for example, you go with your pronation, okay?
When you do side pressure,
you stress your pronator teres muscle, which overlaps with your pronation and will kill your pronation training.
If the next day you will do fingers, because you're feeling that fingers are not side pressure, you will overdo flexor digitorum superficialis, which is also used in the side pressure.
So it's really small chance that you will find a split that will
allow you to hit different muscles.
And even if you will do it, because it is possible, but even if you will, it is not arm wrestling specific and it's not optimal.
Because what we want to do actually is we want to train as much muscle as we can do in one rep.
So we want to have our rising loaded, pronation loaded, fingers,
know flexors back chest shoulder everything together and then you go and do your rep this is how you get stronger in arm wrestling so doing any kind of maxes doing any kind of you know more complex more similar to arm wrestling exercises will not allow you to split it and you are doing your table time which obviously also will you want it or not will target
Pretty much everything.
You can go top roll, so okay, all in all, it will be a little bit less challenge or, you know, bottom fingers maybe.
But depends how you're top rolling.
If you go hook, yes, maybe a little bit rising will be not that stressed.
Still, we are working on the same muscles.
So you will be overtrained and you are overtraining.
And what it leads to, what overtraining is leading to?
Because you can say, okay, but my body will adapt to.
Well, not really.
You will injure yourself.
At some point, the gains you think you make faster because you are killing yourself every week, they will stop because when you will get this one tiny injury, it will stay there for weeks or months or years and will not allow you to progress as fast as you could without this.
So how can you tell when you're fresh or not?
In my opinion, the best way is to check it with your max day.
So not everyone is working this way, but I do.
And beginning of my max day is few isolated lifts.
So here, here, okay.
What else do I have?
Here, right?
I have few isolated lifts.
and I see if I am stronger than the last week, if my rate of force development is way worse, and if I'm not that strong as I was the last week, it mean that I did something wrong because I should be hitting pretty much the same peak as I did before because I'm not weaker, I trained whole week.
So if you are weaker the next week, the same day,
Same setup.
It means that you are overtraining.
There are ways to measure it.
And for example, if you have dynamometer, you can find very strict exercise.
So for example, you attach a chain at the bottom and you do just strict back pressure or biceps curl, hammer curl.
And if you see that something's wrong on dynamometer, well, then you have overtrained.
But what if you don't have this thing and you don't work on your max strength every week?
I suggest you do.
You do it because it's good, it is effective, but let's say you don't.
Let's say you're going with classic, old-school bodybuilding style of arm wrestling.
Well, if you feel that you need, and this is pretty important because not many people are talking about that.
if you obviously if you have 10 so tender places your fascia is not released that's obvious right but if you go to the sparring session if you start your lifts and before you will get your desired way so let's say you are curling even curling is not good for arm wrestling in my opinion so you are curling and you need to go three sets before hitting your max weight
for warm up or you need to have like very long 20, 30, 40 minutes warm up to safely go to your max.
The longer time you need to warm up, I'm not saying you shouldn't warm up, I'm not saying you shouldn't warm up, but if you feel that you need this warm up to safely take this weight, there is huge chance that you are overtraining because for some reason,
the better arm wrestling week I had, the shorter time I need to get my max.
And usually I get my max in second attempt.
And I've seen that when I cut my volume down,
I don't need to warm it up like a crazy.
So for example, I do my thumb, side, back pressure move.
I will warm up myself like I will go one, maybe lightly, second time, heavier.
And before that, I will just do some random pull-ups and dip just to warm my nervous system and put my blow.
That's it.
And after this one, I'm hitting my max.
So if you need more time,
to hit your max, to give yourself maximum effort, your body doesn't want it.
And why your body doesn't want it?
Because it's over-trained.
So the most important thing in progress in armwrestling is to structure your volume to the level that week to week at the same time, you are not weaker but stronger
not always you can be stronger, but you are not weaker or not significantly weaker than you were before.
And if you are new to arm wrestling and you are doing like this, I'm sorry, stupid sparring session, I'm done, then you are overtraining.
Because eccentric moves are challenging you way more.
One more thing, you believe you are doing isometric, why you are not doing isometric, you do eccentrics.
I said that before, but I have to repeat it once again.
If you pull and open yourself just a little bit, you are already in eccentrics.
And eccentrics are more challenging.
So if you take a study, whatever, some coach will tell you, do isometrics this way.
And these isometrics are not really isometrics.
then you should cut the volume down because you are not able, I'm pretty okay if I have something here and I'm just do isometric contraction because without eccentric phase, I can do pretty much twice more of this kind of volume than this fake isometrics.
And still I'm talking about doing it heavily because if you do it very light, then it doesn't work for arm sling.
But anyway, so if you,
do isometrics in not proper way and they turn into eccentrics, your volume has to be compressed too.
So change your training to proper isometrics or maybe get cut off the volume.
Overlapping muscles, every time you do your rows, you do your pull-ups, like for example, if you do pull-ups like that and then you train your back pressure and you don't
Consider this one to be something that is fatiguing you.
That's also an error.
So you need to be conscious about your muscles, what they are responsible for, and you need to structure your training so you don't use this muscle.
Even if you have non-armwrestling training next day, you can already kill your, for example, biceps or, you know,
brachioradialis with doing some pull-ups.
So instead, next day you want to do back, okay?
So instead of doing it like that, go this way, okay?
This way, you have lower chances to overwork your brachioradialis.
There is many small factor like that, but this is something that you have to focus on because if you're gonna ignore your overtraining, you're gonna kill your progress.
That's it.
There is no doubt about that.
And you can check...
like a lot of people start to talk about that because the mind's a little bit changed because in the past was more more more more is better you know and now we start to understand like yeah there is a limit for more that you can benefit from and be very aware aren't the training shouldn't make you feel bad and it shouldn't hurt if it hurts on a regular basis
you are going into wrong direction.
But the most important thing is measure it and then you will know if you are overtraining or not.
That's it.
Bye.